[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
THIS WEEK MARKED THE FIRST 500
DAYS OF DONALD TRUMP'S
PRESIDENCY OR WHAT I LIKE TO
CALL THE FIRST 500 DAYS OF
DONALD TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY.
[LAUGHTER]
I CELEBRATE A LITTLE EACH DAY.
THAT IS ME.
500 DAYS.
500 DAYS OF THE MEDIA'S NERVOUS
BREAKDOWN BEGAN.
A LOT OF STUFF HAPPENED
THEN ESPECIALLY FOR YOU IN YOUR
LIFE AND THAT IS WHAT MATTERS,
NOT US, YOU.
THE MATTER WHAT THE MEDIA SAYS
LIFE WENT ON WITHOUT THE
PREDICTED CATASTROPHES.
YOUR LIFE STAY THE SAME OR IT
GOT BETTER AND IF IT GOT WORSE,
I BLAME OBAMA.
[LAUGHTER]
NO, I AM KIDDING.
STOP, DON'T APPLAUD.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
EVEN IF NOTHING CHANGED THAT IS
NOT WHAT WAS PREDICTED.
THE TRUMPETS OF DOOM WARNED OF
FINANCIAL MELTDOWNS, CIVIL WARS
AND NUCLEAR ARMAGEDDON.
INSTEAD WE HAVE PEACEFUL
PROSPERITY, LOWER TAXES, A REAL
CHANCE WITH NORTH KOREA, A
BOOMING ECONOMY AND AS AN ADDED
BONUS KATHY GRIFFIN WENT STONE
BUNKERS.
[LAUGHTER]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. TRUMP.
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE AGE.
EVEN IF THE MEDIA CAN'T SEE IT
OR REFUSES TO SO, IF THIS IS HOW
THE MEDIA ACTS NOW IMAGINE HOW
THEY WOULD BE ACTING IF THINGS
WERE ACTUALLY BAD.
REALLY HATES PHONES.
IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL THIS GOOD
NEWS THE MEDIA INSERTS FOR BAD.
THEY'RE LIKE THOSE PIGS THAT DIG
FOR TRUFFLES EXCEPT THOSE
STORIES LIKE WHERE IS MELANIA
TRUMP?
OH, THERE SHE IS.
NEVERMIND ABOUT MELANIA TRUMP.
MEANWHILE, YOU SHRUG.
THE MEDIA COMPLAINING ABOUT HOW
THE NEWS CREATE UNEASE THAT'S A
MOSQUITO COMPLAINING ABOUT
MALARIA.
IT'S WHINING ABOUT RABIES, IRAQ
STAR DEPLORING
STAR DEPLORING CHLAMYDIA.
ISN'T IT OBVIOUS HOW FREQUENTLY
THEY AVOID THE GOOD?
THE MAY HAVE THE NERVE TO RUN
STORIES SAYING THAT BAD NEWS
MAKES YOU SICK.
NO, IT'S NOT BAD NEWS THAT MAKES
YOU SICK BUT THAT YOU ARE BAD
NEWS THAT HURTS.
WITH EACH NEGATIVE STORY MAKES
YOU THE VIEWER A VILLAIN AND IS
THE CLIMATE WARMING?
IT IS YOUR FAULT, YOU SELFISH
CONSUMER.
RISING INEQUALITY?
YOU EVIL CAPITALIST PIGS.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANKLY, NOT GOOD FOR AMERICA TO
HOURLY THAT AMERICA SUCKS.
IF ONLY THERE WAS A SOLUTION FOR
THIS IN THE SOLUTION THAT
SOMEHOW INVOLVES A DOLPHIN.
>> RACIST?
>> YES, YES.
>> ALL THE PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> WE LIVE IN A CULTURE THAT
HATES WOMEN.
>> DEPRESSING.
>> THE WORLD IS TERRIBLE AND
IT'S ALL MY FAULT.
YES, IT IS ALL YOUR FAULT, TOM.
>> YEAH, YOU, TOM.
ALL THIS BAD NEWS IS YOUR FAULT.
YOU ARE DESTROYING THE WORLD IN
YOUR HEARTLESS BIGOT.
IN SHORT, YOU SUCK AND YOU ARE A
HORRIBLE HUMAN BEING.
>> I FEEL SICK.
>> GREAT.
I HAVE DONE MY JOB.
>> SOUND LIKE SOMEONE NEEDS AND
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT DOLPHIN.
IT'S A NORMAL-SIZED DOLPHIN THAT
HAS BEEN GENETICALLY ALTERED TO
THE SIZE OF THE PERSON AND GIVEN
LAKES.
WHEN YOU ARE SICK FROM THE BAD
NEWS HE WILL BE THERE TO REMIND
YOU OF LIFE.
>> IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT.
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WHEN A COWORKER TRIES TO BUM
YOU OUT.
>> IF YOU ARE STILL DRIVING TO
WORK YOU OBVIOUSLY HATE THE
PLANET.
>> IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT.
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT.
>> OR EVEN WHEN YOU LEAST EXPECT
IT.
>> IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT.
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT.
>> THAT SOUNDS ANNOYING BUT I
GUESS IT BEATS THE SICKNESS AND
SADNESS.
>> GET THE IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT
DOLPHIN TODAY.
WE WILL FLOW IN A IT'S GOING TO
BE OKAY SHARK.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: THE SELECT MANAGEMENT KNOW
THE NO DRUGS WERE TAKEN WHEN WE
CAME UP WITH THAT IDEA
CAME UP WITH THAT IDEA.
EVERYTHING IS VIEWED WITH THE
SAME FOLDER FROM ACADEMIA WHICH
AND CREATES ONE CONCLUSION, YOU
ARE THE OPPRESSOR.
IF THAT DOES NOT MAKE YOU SICK,
IT SHOULD.
RIGHT NOW IF YOU GROUND THINGS
ARE PRETTY GOOD.
WE NOW HAVE MORE JOBS AVAILABLE
THAT WE HAVE JOBLESS AND I NEVER
HEARD OF THAT BEFORE AND THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A NEWS.
IS THAT RIGHT MSNBC?  BOTTOM
LINE THE MEDIA TRYING TO
DIAGNOSE CAN ONLY BE DONE WITH
THE MIRROR.
THEY NEED TO LOOK AT IT AND NOT
JUST USE IT TO DO IS OFF.
THE MEDIA IS THE PROGRESSIVE
HAMMER.
[LAUGHTER]